You may ask yourself: What does Dwayne ‘The
Rock’ Johnson and his charismatic personality
have to do with a video about One Piece? After
all you can´t really say that these two topics
are too closely related, right?
But what if I told you that the Rock and One
Piece DO have something in common. Or rather
that there is a character in the story of
One Piece that closely resembles Johnson in
more than just one way.
Franky is without a doubt one of the more
flashy characters in the story. At first glance,
comparing him to the Rock may seem a little
superficial, but I promise you that it will
all make sense, once we make it to the end
of this video. So, bear with me here.
To be completely honest with you, I personally
didn't really like Franky as a character too
much for quite some time. And I can’t really
tell you why. Maybe it was his unusual character
design or his rowdy-like language that didn´t
speak to me, but I simply couldn’t enjoy
him as a character as much as I did the other
straw hats at that time. And then, as a grew
older and got more and more involved with
One Piece, I noticed something weird. I caught
myself liking the chapters and scenes with
Franky more and more and before I knew it,
I thought that he was actually an amazing
character. How the hell did that happen? As
I came to realize, my mistake was, that I
thought that Franky was designed to appeal
to younger readers. And in a certain way that
is probably true. But the way his character
is designed actually resonates a lot more
with my older self. So, let´s find out who
Franky the Cyborg truly is and why Oda might
have written the Rock into One Piece by accident.
Franky is a powerfully built, tall man with
a height of at least seven feet…or a little
over 2 meters in case you´re like me and
don´t know how much that is. An immediate
eyecatcher are Franky´s forearms, which are
enormously big while his biceps are comparatively
small. The same goes for his muscular upper
body, with unproportionally thin legs. He
has brightly-colored blue hair and blue star
tattoos on his forearms. Going with his existence
as a cyborg, he has a very geometric looking
face with a metallic nose and a triangular
chin. His choice of clothing usually comprises
of speedos and an open Hawaiian "Aloha" shirt
with a large golden chain necklace around
his neck. Before becoming a cyborg, Franky
went half-naked simply because he felt like
it. Now however, his cyborg body is built
in a way that covering himself up would actually
limit him in using his technical features,
that include a variety of weapons and other,
let´s say interesting features? Also, he
only wears a shirt to cover his back, the
only part of his body he cannot reach and
modify and as a result is most vulnerable
to damage. To make his character even more
quirky and round things up, his body runs
entirely on cola.
Next to Robin, Franky is the only other Straw
Hat that initially started out as an antagonist
for the crew. Franky grew up on Water 7 as
an orphaned boy from the south blue, where
he was thrown overboard by his parents, who
also were pirates, when he was barely 4 years
old. He was found by the legendary shipwright
Tom, who took him in and made him his apprentice.
Franky´s REAL name is Cutty Flam, but his
fellow apprentice Iceburg decided to nickname
him Franky and the name stuck ever since.
When Tom was arrested for building the Oro
Jackson for the pirate king Gol D. Roger,
he managed to evade his sentence by offering
to build a Sea Train in order to help the
struggling city. Together with Iceburg and
Franky he managed to finish the train in time.
However, Spandam, an official of the World
Government, framed Tom for attacking Water
7 using Franky´s own personal fleet of mini
battle ships, that he had built to fight off
the sea kings. His goal was to get his hands
on the blueprints of the ancient weapon Pluton,
that was in Tom´s possession.
When Tom was taken to Enies Lobby on the Sea
Train, Franky tried to stand in its path and
was run over. Heavily injured, he drifted
to a ship where he modified his own body into
a cyborg and returned to Water Seven several
years later. He revealed himself to Iceburg,
who was now the mayor of the prospering Water
Seven. From him Franky received the plans
for the Pluton, and he decided to protect
Iceburg and Water 7 from the shadows. To do
so, he became a ship dismantler, bounty hunter
and thug and form the Franky Family, taking
in cast outs from the city. So now that we
know Franky´s crazy and tragic story, let´s
look at his character.
Franky has been filled with positive characteristics
by Oda, that maybe aren´t apparent at first
glance. But let´s start with a more obvious
one: Franky has shown us over and over again
how strong-willed he is. And he takes it to
the utmost extreme, by performing self-surgery
and modification on himself while he was at
the verge of death, after being run over by
the sea train. This is a feat that maybe even
a Luffy or Zoro would have difficulties with,
regardless of the technical knowledge involved.
Hand in hand with this go his craftiness,
his sharp wit and his creativity that make
him such a unique shipwright. Franky is one
of the very few people that are able to create
and handle technology on an advanced level.
Not only is his cyborg technology incredibly
advanced, but he also had no problem understanding
and integrating Dr. Vegapunk inventions during
the time skip.
Franky also has a very free-spirited and eccentric
personality. He is proud to be who he is,
with all his quirks and unique features and
doesn´t like to follow social norms let alone
the law of the world government. This also
reflects really well in his language that
is kind of punky and includes him rolling
his R.
Another side of Franky that often gets overlooked
is his altruism and kindness towards others.
Whether it is with the children on Punk Hazard
or the Tontatta on Dressrosa, our Cyborg clearly
cares, not only for his crew and family but
also those around him in general. This is
closely related to his emotional side, that
makes him tear up very quickly when hearing
a tragic story.
Most importantly though, and I think this
is one of the core messages of this video,
Franky is actually incredibly mature, despite
all his goofiness. When stopping the sea train,
he shouts that he wants to be like his father
figure Tom. Someone who took him in, even
after his parents abandoned him. So that´s
what he did. He went through the streets of
Water 7 and took in those people who had been
forgotten by everyone else. He gave them a
family and a place to belong. We can also
see this in Franky´s relationship with everyone
in the crew. He takes on the role of a kind
of father or big brother for especially the
younger ones, teaching Usopp about engineering,
taking care of Chopper and supporting those
who need him, like Luffy in Dressrosa and
Robin in Enies Lobby. While we often see him
goofing around and entertaining the crew,
he always seems to keep serious matters in
mind. And his world view in general is one
of the most mature in the crew as well. I
think this maturity was something that I didn´t
manage to see when I was younger, and it explains
why I came to love Franky as a character a
little later than some of the other Straw
Hats. It seems to go against his character
and yet, when you look at the big picture
fits perfectly.
Interestingly enough, this maturity also reflects
in Franky´s drivers for character development.
Because in a way, he truly is already matured.
His only real inner need is his inability
to forgive himself for the death of his master
Tom. Otherwise Franky doesn´t really have
anything he has to change I order to become
a better person. Yes, he indeed did do some
immoral things, like beating Usopp or stealing
from pirates like the straw hats. But he mostly
did all of those out of a sense of atonement
and love. In memory of Tom, he decided to
spend the rest of his days on Water 7, attacking
incoming thieves and looters, organizing all
the thugs so that he could keep the city´s
crime in check and overall protecting the
city that Tom loved so much.
Franky´s dream on the other hand is really
hands on: He wanted to create a dream ship
out of Adam Wood and see it sail around the
world. In other words, Franky is literally
living his dream with the straw hats at the
moment. At the same time, he strives to become
stronger to be able to protect his friends
on their dangerous journey. No wonder then
that Franky values family and kindness as
much as he values freedom and of course craftsmanship.
How then does this impressive cyborg of a
man influence the story?
Being the shipwright of the straw hats, Franky
is the one enabling the crew to sail on the
dangerous waters of the grand line in the
first place. He was the one who built the
Sunny and also is the one to repair her and
keep her in good shape over the course of
their journey. In other words: Franky quite
literally is responsible for moving the plot
along. Apart from his duties as a craftsman
though, he also is an important fighting asset,
when things get a little heated. And more
often than not, he actually plays a major
role in events taking place. On Enies Lobby,
he helped the Straw Hats save Robin. As a
matter of fact, he was the one to unchain
and protect her until the rest of the crew
arrived. And later he helped everyone escape
by using a Coup de Vent, blowing the blockade
of buster call ships apart and sending the
Going Merry flying through the air. But he
also knows how to support his fighting friends,
as we could see on Dressrosa, where he took
care of Luffy during his fight with Doflamingo.
Another detail, that is often forgotten, is
that Franky most likely still holds the knowledge
of how to rebuild the ancient weapon Pluton.
A plot point that might well become relevant
again down the line. And finally, in terms
of character development, he also provides
guidance for the younger crew members, helping
them feeling safe and comfortable on this
dangerous journey. In that context, it is
of course also worth looking at Franky´s
own character arc.
Since Franky has a very mature and as a result
nearly complete character, his development
over the course of the story is rather minor
and altruistic. Franky definitely still is
working on overcoming his guilt regarding
Tom´s death, but it is nothing that Oda puts
too much into focus for us. Still, we can
see Franky making progress in this regard,
be it defeating Spandam, who was responsible
for his pain, joining the straw hats, meeting
Tom´s brother Dan on Fishman Island or simply
fulfilling his dream, sailing with his friends.
It is a very low-key, but nonetheless fulfilling
change of character, that I hope will be brought
up again at one point in the story.
For his character as a whole, I feel like
there are three arcs in particular where Franky
was at the center of events. The first one
is obviously the Water 7 and Enies Lobby arc.
And yes, that is also Robin´s big arc, no
doubt about it. But that Oda managed to make
it the major point of events for not just
one but TWO straw hats, just confirms for
me how great this arc truly was. Starting
out as antagonists, Luffy and Franky came
to forgive and trust each other over the course
of events. And after all they went through
together, in the end there really was no other
option for either of them to not journey together
from then on out.
The time skip was another confirmation about
how important Franky would be for the crew.
Stranded on the island of Karakuri, the hometown
of the infamous Dr. Vegapunk, he was able
to further improve himself as well as the
sunny. All that for the sake of protecting
his friends and making the Sunny into a ship
of dreams for the crew.
Finally, Franky got to play a major role in
the events unfolding on Dressrosa, where not
only he showed true bravery and kindness in
protecting the Tontatta and Luffy, but also
had an ideologically amazing fight against
Senor Pink of the Donquixote family. Franky
may not seem like it at first glance, but
he truly is a fantastic character, that is
much more complex and contributes much more
to the plot than one would think.
So why the Rock? I hope by now you already
have a feeling what I´m talking about here.
Because Franky and Dwayne Johnson actually
share a lot of similarities, and in more than
one way. Let´s start with some of the more
obvious ones. I personally think that both
Franky AND the Rock are extremely likable
characters. They both have a very positive
aura around them and basically ooze energy
and motivation. Then of course there is the
look. [Franky next to the Rock] I mean c´mon.
If these guys don´t look similar I don´t
know. Beside the thing with the glasses, which
I found super hilarious once I realized it
by the way, thy both have the bulky, muscular
‘Strong Man’ look. They also both have
a connection to Hawaii and Oda actually stated
that Franky would be American, if One Piece
took place in the real world. I mean these
are minor things, but I just feel like they
round off the analogy quite well.
Then of course we have their upbringing. Both
had a difficult childhood. But they also managed
to work their way out of there through their
enthusiasm and positivity and finally managed
to lead a life that brings them happiness
every day.
Finally, I feel like they also resemble each
other immensely in their personality. Both
strongly value kindness and humor and both
are extremely eccentric and free-spirited.
Now that I think about it, in a way they even
resemble each other in the way they changed
over the years. Pre-time skip Franky, with
his rowdy-like appearance really reminds me
of a younger wrestling-Rock, while post-time
skip Franky is closer to the Dwayne Johnson
today. Mature, altruistic and somehow looking
more like a tank than before. So, there you
have it. With Franky, Oda has created a truly
amazing character and by accident he might
have made the Rock join the straw hats.
Hey everybody. Thank you so much for watching.
Making this video turned out to be a lot more
fun than I expected. I really enjoy making
all of these videos, but for Franky I just
kept coming across these small details that
I just found so fascinating.
Also, I will be answering some of your questions
in the comments below. So, don´t forget to
leave a comment and maybe even a like.
Today, I also want to give a shout out to
my wonderful translators. A big thank you
to Hannah and Rodri Uribe, who translated
my last video into German and Spanish. You
are a huge help in growing this community
and making this content accessible to more
people. If you should also be interested in
creating captions for this or any other video
on my channel, you can either contact me on
twitter or simply start right away. YouTube
will let you translate everything line by
line, very straight forward.
Also, a big thank you to all my Patreon supporters,
who enable me to create content for you on
a regular basis. If you also want to support
this channel, you can find the link to my
page in the comments below.
Finally, if you want to hear more from me,
make sure to follow me on Twitter.
If you liked this video, don´t forget to
like share and subscribe to be notified for
any future content of mine. Or dislike, don´t
share and unsubscribe, it´s a free world
people.
I hope to see you around next time and until
then, have a great week.
… Oh yeah and don´t forget to turn your
notifications on! YouTube can sometimes be…forgetful.
Bye!